unlv's medical school holding its second  graduation ceremony ever at the thomason  mack center today as you can see 55  students took the hippocratic oath and  became doctors we're told that they're  all across the nation all have strong  ties to the silver state one thing for  sure really an unfor unforgettable  experience for these bright young  individuals  loss for words i'm ecstatic i  this played out more than i would have  imagined  i think  when i first  came to this school when i first even  interviewed at this school i knew that  there was going to be something special  justin there is going into work in  general surgery we wish him the best i  love the lower third there denise just  became a doctor